[♪ suspenseful music plays]
[Officer Cisneros]
A suit machine gun.
Okay, I can see by the
mechanism that this isn't a toy.
Has a magazine.
It's an airsoft magazine.
Shoots pellets.
The problem that
we have with this,
it must have a orange tip
that is attached to it that
you cannot remove.
This one doesn't have it.
This is just painted.
So that's not, a no-no for us.
And plus, this is a
very realistic looking gun.
When this realistic gun
is in the hands of a child,
if a police officer comes by
and sees somebody pointing this
gun to kids, what do you think
that this officer will do?
Will actually meet the guy
with the gun with deadly force.
There is no need in our
society to have realistic
guns in the playground.
There is no need for it.
If we cannot confiscate
it by the orange tips,
I see "Made in Wisconsin,
United States."
If it was made in
Wisconsin, United States,
why is it coming from Europe?
Also they have the trademark.
So we have some grounds to
actually confiscate this gun
as an IPR,
Intellectual Property Rights,
violation or look for
more information about,
you know, how we can go around
and trying to stop this gun
from reaching our population.
Let's see what else we have.
So now we're gonna X-ray those,
this big parcels.
Okay, what do we have here?
Hmm.
This one seems that the
middle part is very dense.
The parcel's coming from
Poland and it's going to L.A.
And we have here puzzles.
Whoa.
Okay, this looks
like something else.
So what I'm gonna do
now is gonna put my mask,
make sure that we
take all the precautions.
So I'm gonna just
make a little cut.
So let me just rip this.
And bingo.
I see pills here.
And we have another one.
More pills here.
And here we go, that's the way.
Same.
So I'm gonna smash them
and then test them to find out
what substance we have here.
[thudding]
Now we've got MDMA.
We're gonna wrap everything up,
we're gonna set
everything where it belongs,
and we're gonna send it
for controlled delivery.
So the bad guy, when
somebody's knocking at the door,
might be a federal officer,
where you're gonna spend
a long, long time
in the penitentiary.